[Music]
if you could turn everything you touched
into gold
how soon would your life become
unbearable
why would this superpower not make you
rich
[Music]
why could things around you explode
and how could one touch end all life on
the planet
this is what if and here's what would
happen if everything you touched turned
into gold
you wake up and discover that you now
have a superpower
anything your hands touch would
immediately become solid gold
like your bed
naturally this calls for a selfie you
reach for your phone but suddenly it
turns into the precious metal right
before your very eyes
it sure is amazing and quite scary
whatever you touch even unintentionally
transforms
you can't brush your teeth eat breakfast
or even drive to work
and if you think you wouldn't need to
work a day in your life with all these
riches
think again
you'd soon understand why you could
single-handedly make gold the cheapest
metal on earth
so
how would you manage to do
anything
okay you try putting gloves on but
surprise surprise these also turn into
gold
yeah it's very impractical but at least
these golden gloves will now act as a
barrier between your hands and your
surroundings
you'd now have to maneuver and do
everything with your arms elbows and
your brand new but yet quite stiff
golden mittens
with your hands so out of commission you
need to ask your family and friends for
help with getting dressed and making
meals
then there's eating
ever try stuffing your mouth with metal
bricks on your hands
as you learn more about your new ability
you might suspect that there are things
you should never touch again yeah you'd
be right
no more physical contact with anyone
scratching the belly of your neighbor's
cat is out unless priceless feline
sculptures are your thing
but hold on for a second
your new power is a little more complex
than that
maybe everything you touch might not be
so perfect in its appearance
the reality might blow
up your mind
one atom of gold has 79 protons and 118
neutrons
let's just say it's pretty dense
tungsten platinum iron
gold beats them all which would be a
huge problem for you
yeah if you started running around and
turning everything into gold atoms at
the molecular level would become too
dense and start to repel each other
everything you transform
would explode
to avoid this your power wouldn't
instantly turn boring molecules into
gold molecules
it would shake them up to make
everything you touch gold while keeping
its original shape and size
except that would make objects look kind
of spongy
because in this scenario there would be
a lot of wiggle room between these new
atoms
well hey better than explosions right
indeed
just don't trip and accidentally touch
the ground
if you did
earth's entire crust would suddenly have
a little extra give to it
and this would be bad news for every
living thing on the planet
the forces of gravity would compress
earth to close up all those new
microscopic spaces
and as the earth shrunk
the ground would move away from your
feet
you and everything around you would
become suspended in the air as earth
gets smaller
when the shrinkage stopped and gravity
kicked in again
that's when your real troubles would
begin
you and nearly 8 billion other people
would feel the deadliest body slam known
to humanity
okay let's go out on a limb here and say
you managed to survive this
well you'd now live on an uninhabitable
globe
surrounded by golden globes of dead
people and animals
growing food would be impossible
no plants means no oxygen
so let's set aside the harsh reality for
a moment to look at what would happen if
every item you place a finger on simply
becomes gold minus the catastrophic
repercussions
well then you could become really rich
in no time
just touch one ceramic mug and it would
now be worth over fifteen thousand
dollars
converting your couch could financially
set you up for life
goodbye student loans hello beachside
villa in the tropics
but don't get too greedy the government
might become suspicious of how you're
affording all this and wonder why you're
not declaring all this extra income
and if the global supply of gold
suddenly skyrocketed its price would
likely crash
your hot commodity might quickly lose
its value
leaving you right back where you started
before discovering your magic hands
there you are months after your power
was bestowed upon you
you wouldn't have the cash you thought
you would
and you'd have to isolate yourself for
the safety of others
you'd be deprived of your need for human
connection
soon enough your loneliness would make
you prone to depression stress and
anxiety
yeah you'd realize that the trade-off
for the golden touch is human contact
and that not even being surrounded by
what was once a precious metal compares
to your actual most valuable asset
your time alongside the ones you care
for
you know there are way better
superpowers out there
like stopping time to enjoy the moments
with people you love but
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]